who'll buy these lovely pears and apples
all delicious and all locally produced
and now that russia's tit-for-tat
sanctions against eu agricultural
imports are starting to bite
there's lots of them hence the eat
belgian drive supported here by mep
turned market trader for a day mark tara
bella
milton de frista
not just parking so
russia's import ban comes as the fruit
harvest is in full swing
it's for a year and includes vegetables
and some dairy and meat products
together they amount to more than 5
billion euros of exports
fruit farmer serge falon says the issue
now is compensation
and he fears many farmers will be forced
to let fruit rot
to qualify so far the eu has pledged 125
million euros
from a 420 million euro emergency fund
no politicians
almost half the pairs belgian farmers
produce go to russia
200 million kilos apples are around 35
million kilos
the loss of such a big market has led to
a glut while producers seek alternatives
and a drop in the price from 50 to 60
euro cents a kilo
to 25. we need immediate help
to cover this costs but secondly
it will be very interesting for us that
european market gives
us the opportunity to export to
interesting markets where
when it's very difficult to go okay we
received some
some some access to the chinese market
but for the moment we still not have
access to the
canadians and the market of usa
meps have been gathering at the
agricultural committee to consider the
eu response and the delicate balance
between imposing political sanctions
and protecting farmer's interests
in poland they're doing much the same as
in belgium only much bigger
by polish and beat putin is the buzz
phrase
poland and the baltic states have been
hardest hit by the russian embargo